JENNY MURPHY: --a question and
answer show, so if any of you
out there would like
to ask questions.
BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
SUSANNAH RAUB: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
RETO MEIER: This is where
the magic happens.
JENNY MURPHY: This is primarily
a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
RYAN BOYD: Hello, everyone.
My name is Ryan Boyd.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I'm
Michael Manoochehri.
RYAN BOYD: And today, we're here
live from Campus London
in London, the United Kingdom,
away from our home base of San
Francisco to talk with you about
what's been exciting
this week in the land
of BigQuery.
So this week, we've actually
done a lot of things.
We've been out amongst the
community talking with the
community and gone to the Strata
Conference and some
other events.
But the real important thing,
which we're here to talk with
you about today, around the
world is the launch that
happened this week.
We had a major launch
for BigQuery.
I think our largest launch,
probably, since we went
general availability.
And that was on JSON support,
nested and repeated support,
and other improvements to
BigQuery import, which makes
it a lot easier for developers
to use BigQuery.
So I want to talk with you about
some of those things.
And we're not going into the
presentation quite yet.
We're just going to have a
little bit of discussion on
what we've been up
to this week.
And that started off this week
with the Strata Conference.
So on Monday, we went to the
Strata London Conference.
And this is one of the premiere
big data conferences
run by O'Reilly.
And I actually gave a talk
on BigQuery at Strata.
And it went over really,
really well.
I only think I had a short
20 minutes, I believe.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It was a
lot to pack in a short time.
RYAN BOYD: It was a lot to
pack in a short time.
But we announced a lot of these
new features at the
Strata Conference a few hours
before they went live on our
blogs, based out of
Mountain View.
And it was really exciting
talking with all the
developers.
I heard afterwards the audience
was abuzz and
chatting amongst themselves
about my query of one terabyte
of data, running regular
expressions on 13 billion rows
in, I think, 23 seconds is what
it took during that talk.
And so there was a lot of
buzz and energy around
BigQuery as a product.
And it was super exciting
to talk with all those
developers.
We also did an Office Hours.
And a number of people stopped
by with various use cases,
from travel agencies to
marketing analytics firms.
A lot of people stopping by and
chatting with us about how
they are currently using
BigQuery, or how they're
planning on using BigQuery.
It was great to hear
this stuff.
If you're not out at one of
these events with us, feel
free to send that information
to us online on Google+.
Let us know how you're
using BigQuery.
It's just really fascinating
for us to hear all the
different use cases that you
guys are using BigQuery for.
And I'm trying to think what
else at Strata Conference.
There was a number
of other talks--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
we did the Data
Science Meetup as well.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
We had the London big Data
Science Meetup where we got to
talk about BigQuery
to their audience.
That was a very short,
five-minute talk.
We basically crammed our
50-minute talk into 20 minutes
for the main Strata Conference,
and then moved it
down to five minutes for the
Data Science Meetup.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
That was a very well-attended
talk.
And we did say we'd be
back sometime to
talk to them again.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: It
was a huge Meetup.
RYAN BOYD: We plan to keep on
coming out here to the UK to
talk with developers.
Do you want to talk, Michael,
about some of the other stuff
outside of the conference?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So yeah,
we did a little tour of some
of the incubators around.
One was TechHub Manchester,
which is opening soon.
And I got to meet with some of
the startups there, some of
the people in Manchester who
are doing really good work
around big data and
the big data area.
I met with a business
intelligence startup, who was
interested in using BigQuery
to have 100% cloud-based
enterprise analytic software.
This is a very small team.
And it just goes to show what
you can do with BigQuery.
It's so powerful, and how
fast you can build.
RYAN BOYD: Their original plan
was just to use a relational
database that they were
familiar with.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
RYAN BOYD: But then they
heard about BigQuery.
And you could just see the
excitement in their face about
the amount of data that could
be crunched with BigQuery.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We always
say it enables you to do
things that you couldn't
do before.
And I think that was the
theme of some of the
startups that I visited.
I also talked to several social
media analytics startups.
And these are also small two-,
three-person teams who are
thinking about using BigQuery
to do some of the data
crunching and data mining that
it takes to really get value
out of social media.
And we also talked
to some ISVs.
We talked to a software vendor
nearby that was using BigQuery
in an end-to-end pipeline,
using some of our partner
tools such as Talon for ETL
and for transformation of
data, and QlikView, which is
another one of our partners,
for visualization of BigQuery
query results.
It was pretty exciting to
see people putting these
technologies together and
building these pipelines.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, absolutely.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Cool stuff.
RYAN BOYD: And we're actually
out here with a bunch of the
other folks from our Cloud
Team, some folks from
AppEngine and folks from
Compute Engine.
And we've all talked to
a bunch of startups.
I actually dived back into my
old world of working on Google
Apps to talk with a number of
folks who are doing some
innovative things around
Google Apps too.
So it was all around a very
exciting event or series of
events around the UK.
And I think we should emphasize
that-- you said
Manchester, but Manchester
is a little
bit outside of London.
But it's exciting to really
see the energy that's
happening throughout the UK.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
RYAN BOYD: It's not just in
London, as we might have
expected coming into this.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah,
it's all over.
I was really impressed with
all the startups and
incubators I visited.
I thought it was great.
And I think there's a really
big scene around--
not just big data-- but startups
in general in London,
Manchester, all over the UK.
It's pretty impressive.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
So hopefully, we'll actually
come out here more to London
and the UK areas in general and
hear more of this and see
more of this.
The Data Science Meetup group
invited us to come back and
give a fuller-length talk.
And we'd love to do that.
So really exciting.
And we're headed off tonight
to Sydney, actually.
We're headed out to Australia
to do a similar type of tour
with a bunch of incubators
and startups.
And we're excited about
that as well.
And I'm trying to think of
what's all in our tour here.
But we're meeting with Google
developer groups.
We did a Google developer
group in London.
I think there's eight events,
basically, we're
packing into two weeks.
So it's great to be out there
amongst the community hearing
what everyone's up to.
And actually, today's
my birthday too.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Happy
birthday, Ryan.
[LAUGHS]
RYAN BOYD: So I get
to actually go
celebrate my birthday.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Woo!
[LAUGHS]
RYAN BOYD: We're headed
to Singapore.
I think we have a six-hour
layover is Singapore.
So we're going to get out and
celebrate my birthday.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's right.
RYAN BOYD: If you want to come
hunt us down in Singapore and
celebrate my birthday we
me, drop me a line.
And I think we're going to a
crab restaurant or something.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: That's for
the few hours we're there,
before we get back
on the plane.
RYAN BOYD: Exactly.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Sounds good.
RYAN BOYD: But all around,
having a good time, but also
hearing a lot about what
developers are up to.
So now let's talk about the
real business, instead of
talking about a party.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
[INAUDIBLE]
up to a terabyte of
data at once.
So a terabyte of data in one
load job, which is an enormous
amount of data.
And also, individual files can
be up to 100 gigabytes per
file, depending on what
type of file it is.
So this is a lot of data.
So Ryan, you were doing some
testing on this earlier.
What was your experience?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
Actually, one of the big things
about the 100 gigabyte
per file is that's actually
uncompressed files.
So uncompressed files, we can
actually shard and do parallel
ingestion on a lot better
than compressed files.
Happy to chat with you about
the reasons behind that in
another venue.
So 100 gigabytes of uncompressed
files.
And the real important thing is
that you're actually able
to send all your files
in at once.
And we just queue them
up for ingestion.
And this makes it much
easier for a
developer to code against.
So previously, what you had is
you had to make sure there
were only, I think, two
ingestion jobs per minute that
you were sending in for
the entire project.
And this meant you really had to
queue up your jobs and send
them to us, do a little
sleeping, do a little
[INAUDIBLE], and
queue them up.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
It put the responsibility
on the developer.
But we're here to
help you out.
RYAN BOYD: --to really make
this easier and put the
responsibility on us to allow
you to ingest a lot of data
really quickly.
So I've been playing
around with this.
And I've been able to ingest
a lot of data.
So previously I had three
terabytes of data that I was
trying to load in.
And that three terabytes of
data, I think, at absolute
optimum, was it 12 hours, I
think, or something like that.
I believe it's 12 hours.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Many,
many hours to get
that much data in.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, at absolute
optimum speed, 12 hours.
And in reality, it took a little
bit longer, because I
didn't shard it perfectly
and that sort of thing.
But now I've actually taken--
sorry, I missed the bullet
point here on that.
But I've actually taken that
data, that three terabytes of
data, and loaded it in in 36
minutes into BigQuery, because
BigQuery doesn't actually
build any indexes.
BigQuery embraces the concept
of a full table scan.
There's actually some comments
from Strata Conference about
how embracing the concept of a
full table scan gave some DBAs
some heart palpitations.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: [LAUGHS]
Yeah.
People gasped at the London
GDG when I said that too.
What?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
So all you DBAs out there,
please, please don't get heart
palpitations.
But we embrace the concept
of full table scan.
And so once you're able
to load this three
terabytes of data in--
and in my example,
in 36 minutes--
you can actually immediately
start querying.
And that's about a 20x
improvement over what it was
before this week, in terms of
how quickly you can start
querying your data.
So really, really awesome
for developers.
Check it out, if you have
a large amount of data.
It makes it a lot easier.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Good stuff.
So let's talk about one of my
favorite subjects, getting
AppEngine Datastore data
into BigQuery.
RYAN BOYD: Before we dive into
this, I do want to mention
that we do have a Google
Moderator.
So for those of you that are
watching this in your Google+
Stream, head over to
developers.google.com/live and
click on this event.
And you'll see embedded in that
page a Google Moderator
that you can ask any questions
that you have as you're
listening to this event.
And we'll visit that Moderator
at the end of this event and
just go through some of those
questions that you have.
We're not doing a live hangout
here today, but we are
answering a lot of the questions
after we have our
little pontificating here.
We're going to answer a lot of
those questions that you have,
either about these features or
about BigQuery in general.
Sorry for the interruption.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Oh,
yeah, no problem.
So yeah.
So one of my favorite subjects
is getting AppEngine Datastore
data into BigQuery, combining
these two technologies to have
a high-availability
datastore--
RYAN BOYD: You're still
jet-lagged.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: I'm
still jet-lagged--
and putting that data into
Google BigQuery.
If you've seen my Google I/O
talk about this, you know we
also have some documentation
on our web site.
But now it's even easier to get
AppEngine Datastore data
into BigQuery.
We've launched a new Trusted
Tester program of a new
feature to put Datastore Admin
backup data into BigQuery.
So let's just give you a
little look at that.
If you enable the AppEngine
Datastore Admin function,
there's a backup feature which
lets you dump Datastore data
into Google Cloud Storage.
And now you can kick off
BigQuery ingestion jobs on
those Datastore data backups.
This is a Trusted
Tester program.
So we're actually getting people
to sign up now, if
you're interested.
Just go to this link
right here.
It's a Google Short Link, qhts,
capital H, to get there.
Or look for it on Ryan's recent
blog post on the Google
Developers blog.
There's a link to the Trusted
Tester program as well.
We're really excited to see what
people do with this and
how you feel about it.
So try it out.
RYAN BOYD: So this actually
shows how you can take data
from a high-availability,
read-write datastore like
AppEngine and bring it into
BigQuery for analysis.
So the datastore is great, if
you need to maintain your
point of record for your data,
high-availability rights, and
quick lookups of your data,
when things match keys and
indexes and that sort of thing,
but then load it into
BigQuery for doing that
aggregate analysis that things
like Datastore aren't really
as fast at doing.
If you're trying to do an
aggregate analysis on
Datastore, you might have to
use, say, AppEngine MapReduce
or something like that to really
loop through all of
your records and do
your analysis.
And that same thing holds true
for other online databases
like NoSQL-type style,
document-style databases.
And we've actually talked with
some of those folks outside of
Google at some of these events
at the AngelHack event that we
were at a couple of weeks ago.
We talked with the FireBase
folks about doing this style
of, basically, get data out of
FireBase and into BigQuery for
analysis in a similar way that
we're doing with AppEngine.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
RYAN BOYD: And it'll be
fantastic to have that level
of integration.
I believe, Michael, you were
actually doing some
experiments too.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
RYAN BOYD: I think you were
planning on doing
some MongoDB work.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
I was playing with MongoDB.
I know a lot of web
devs use MongoDB.
And I think it's a good synergy
between the two
technologies, right?
Use MongoDB for the web
interface back end, and stick
that data into BigQuery.
RYAN BOYD: Did you say the
word synergy, Michael?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: What?
Did I say synergy?
No.
Impossible.
[LAUGHS]
RYAN BOYD: Michael.
Michael.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN BOYD: Anyway--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We'll
synergize on this later.
[LAUGHS]
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
It sounds great, Michael.
Anyway, the word "synergy"
seems to come up in some
business meetings.
And Michael and I, as engineers,
laugh at it now.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Exactly.
[LAUGHTER]
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, so it
should be fantastic.
So we can do it with
AppEngine today.
Sign up for the Trusted
Tester program.
We're interested to know what
your real business use cases
are, what types of value you're
looking to get out of
the data that you currently
are storing in AppEngine.
And then, later on, we'll
definitely be exploring some
of these other NoSQL databases
and document stores and figure
out how we get those integrated
into BigQuery.
If you guys have ideas, or if
you have open source projects,
definitely let us know what
you guys are building.
There's been, actually, a number
of open source projects
around BigQuery recently.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
Yeah, definitely.
Like Ruby Libraries,
there are people
doing logs into BigQuery.
So a good place to follow this--
what we're doing, is
Google Cloud Developers Plus
page, or follow us on our
private pages as well.
And we will share some of these
technologies with you.
RYAN BOYD: And we're actually
thinking about an upcoming
hangout here, upcoming Google
Developers Live session, to
talk about a lot of the open
source efforts around BigQuery
and what some other developers
are doing.
And maybe we can even invite
some of those developers to
the Google Developers Live.
So look forward to that.
And let us know, in the
meantime, what you're doing.
So preparing your data.
We just want to talk a
little bit about--
we talked about JSON and
nested/repeated as one of the
things that we launched, I
believe, on October 1, at the
beginning of this week.
And we just wanted to compare
the different styles of data.
Sometimes it's helpful to see it
in a graphic form what the
different styles of data looks
like and how you can work with
it in BigQuery.
So typically, a lot of our
developers are familiar with
relational databases.
So this is a relational database
schema where you have
two separate tables and you've
done normalization--
which are taught a lot in
college database classes--
to basically separate out the
data so that, for instance, if
you have people here, and each
person has maybe lived in
multiple cities, that you
basically only have one
definitive record per person.
And then you have separate
records for the cities that
they've lived in.
And you link the two
up on a key.
And that's really useful if
you are trying to maintain
consistency in a database
environment, which is often a
read-write database environment
and you want to
make sure that you have
perfect consistency.
But you don't necessarily need
that relational schema when
you're trying to do
large-scale aggregate analysis.
And in fact, at times, it's a
lot faster to do large-scale
aggregate analysis when
you don't have
that relational schema.
So BigQuery has always taught
you to do a denormalized form
where you take and make every
single one of the rows.
It's essentially a join.
And you're doing a pre-join on
your data when you're loading
it into BigQuery.
And you could represent that
in a CSV format quite well.
That denormalized form worked
well in a CSV format.
And that's the primary data
format that BigQuery did
support previously, and the
only format we supported
previously.
But we've now looked and said,
all right, well, what about
JSON as a data format?
And we can represent the data
that you would represent in a
CSV in a JSON object
fairly easily.
It looks a little heavier
weight, as you see here,
because you're repeating the
names of the fields over and
over again.
But as soon as you compress this
data, it compresses down
pretty small.
We did use a Newline-delimited
JSON format.
I want to stress that.
You can see the backslash
ends at the end of
each of these lines.
In reality, this would only
be two lines of text.
But on the slide, it's
a lot easier to
communicate it as it is here.
And the Newline-delimited format
allows us to really
efficiently do things like
parallel ingestion of the data
that you're putting into
the JSON format.
But you can see here, we've
just, basically, taken that
CSV format and put
it into JSON.
It's a little more expressive,
a little easier to read, but
doesn't add a huge amount of
value, other than potentially
supporting some existing
JSON-based document stores and
that sort of thing.
But that's not all we've done.
What we've done that adds a lot
of value is giving you the
ability to do nested data.
So you can see here, we went
from the normalized form to
the denormalized form.
And now we've given you the
ability to represent structure
in your data through nested
and repeated values.
And that structure really helps
make it much easier for
people who are looking at your
data, developing against your
data, and also as you're
loading your data, to
understand the underlying
structure of your data.
In terms of the actual querying
support that it
provides, we can jump into
the queries here
a little bit later.
But the queries aren't that
much more expressive.
You're not able to do that many
more different things
with the nested data, but it
makes it a lot easier to
understand and a lot easier to
read and basically represents
how humans think a lot better,
in sort of an object-oriented
nested format.
So you can see what that might
look here for a table of
people versus where they lived,
various cities that
they lived in.
And then we support that now in
JSON and be able to express
that data in JSON format.
And you can see here this
represents something like a
birth record in this particular
record here.
And a birth record, it's one of
our example data sets, the
CDC birth statistics data.
And you have each baby born
in the US represents
a row of that data.
And in here, you have
the states that the
mother has lived in.
The baby was born in 1979.
The mother's lived in three
different states.
That's showing the repeated
structure of BigQuery.
And then, in terms of the nested
and repeated structure,
we have the health
scores here.
So they take a score, a
measurement of a baby's health
after they're born, a couple of
minutes after they're born,
maybe 10 minutes after
they're born.
Back in 1979, maybe they only
took two measurements.
So you would have the time at
five minutes and the time at
10 minutes, and what the baby's
health was at each of
those times.
But let's say, nowadays, they
want to start collecting
additional measurements.
You can use the same schema,
and just add an additional
time as you load new records
into BigQuery.
So it's really powerful in
a way that allows you to
structure your data a lot
better, makes it a lot more
readable, and a lot more
workable when you're writing
your queries.
So let's give you a few examples
of queries here.
Here's one example of querying
nested and repeated data, a
very simple example where
we can say that the
mother_substance_used.alcohol
equals true.
So you could have a bunch of
different substance_used
properties.
I probably shouldn't go through
the whole list of
various substances that a mother
could use that would
affect the health
of their baby.
But
mother_substance_used.alcohol
here equals true.
And really, that dot syntax
allows you to just express
what the nested value is.
And then where you get a little
bit more complicated is
when you're actually--
well, complicated might
not be the right term.
Where you're able to be a little
more expressive here is
when you're trying to look
at the nested data.
And for instance, in this case,
we're trying to figure
out the average number of states
a mother has lived in
before giving birth
to their child.
And maybe you want to correlate
that, versus the
health scores or the substances
used or something.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: This is
an interesting query too,
because the amount of states a
mother has lived in can be a
variable between
records, right?
So you could have somebody can
be living in five states over
their lifetime, maybe two
states in another one.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
And you're trying to
figure out what the
average number is.
And that's what this WITHIN
statement, WITHIN RECORD, can
give you a COUNT.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Right.
RYAN BOYD: And then you can do
an aggregate on the outside of
that, as a SuperSelect of the
Subselect statement here, and
get the average number
of states that a
mother has lived in.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
That's great.
So it's a very natural way
to model the data.
If this was in a flat record,
it would just be a lot of
repeated values over and
over in the records.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, exactly.
So it really allows you to
repeat your data a lot less.
And the underlying storage is
a lot less, when you have
these nested/repeated records.
It's kind of ironic that
repeated records allow you to
repeat your data a lot less.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
RYAN BOYD: But anyway during
the ingestion process,
basically, you don't have to
repeat the values for every
single row as you flatten
out the data.
So super valuable.
And I think that this release
really represents what we're
trying to do with BigQuery,
trying to make Google's
underlying technologies
available to you.
A lot easier to use than even
some of the functionality that
Google has internally.
We're adding that layer of
ease on top of it for the
developers to be able to get
their data in quickly in a
format that they're accustomed
to using with other NoSQL
databases and other document
stores and using elsewhere on
the web in various APIs
the JSON format.
And in the nested-repeated
structure, that's a lot easier
for developers to understand and
then eventually query on.
So I think that really sums up
this release is it just makes
it a lot easier for developers
to import data in a structure
they understand and then
query upon it.
Anything else, before we head
off to the Office Hours?
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: No.
Let's do it.
Let's check out what
people are asking.
RYAN BOYD: All right, so we're
going to ask questions from
the audience.
But you can express
these questions
over in Google Moderator.
Again, just going to
developers.google.com/life and
click on the event here today.
And you'll see a Moderator
embedded there.
You can ask your questions.
I think there's already some
questions over there, so we're
going to head over and check out
on my browser here, check
out what questions there are, if
I can learn how to operate
my computer.
That's always a challenge
for me.
So let's see here.
Here's our Moderator.
So it looks like we have five
questions from six people.
And we'll just go
through the--
let's see here.
Does running queries--
so let's go through the
top to bottom here.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
All right.
RYAN BOYD: So you want to talk
about the first question.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah.
So this one here?
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So does
running queries with the
unions on lots of tables affect
the performance in
terms of the time it takes to
return the query result?
So what this question is
referring to is it's possible
to run queries over tables with
the same schema by doing
a union query, basically listing
the table names in the
query, running the query over
multiple tables at once.
RYAN BOYD: Because, oftentimes,
you'll actually
shard your data in BigQuery.
For instance, I was looking at
the Wikipedia page views.
And I sharded that data.
It's huge amounts of data.
I sharded that data by month.
So I could look and only embrace
the full table scan on
a month of data at a time,
because often you'll only need
to actually query the
most recent month or
something like that.
So you'll shard your data.
But then, at times, you
do want to query over
many months of data.
And actually the 13 billion rows
thing that I talked about
was created over many months of
data in a union query like
this talks about.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI:
Yeah, definitely.
By the way, for more information
about sharding and
table design, Ryan and I have
written a new ingestion
cookbook on our web site, which
is best practices for
data ingestion and schemas
and sharding,
and things like that.
To get back to this question,
because of the design of
BigQuery, actually there's a
very negligible performance
hit when you do these
kind of things.
Actually, the queries are
returned very quickly.
And that's due to the
distributed design of BigQuery.
So you shouldn't see any
performance hit when you run
over multiple tables.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah.
If you look at our Google I/O
video that I did along with
one of the core engineers on
the BigQuery back end, we
actually explain a lot of the
underlying BigQuery structure
and how it processes queries.
So if you're a true query geek,
a true database geek,
you might want to
check that out.
And you can see how each leaf
node only processes a small
chunk of data.
It really doesn't matter what
table that chunk of data is
coming from.
It doesn't change the
performance characteristics.
So the next one here, I
guess I'll take this.
The data I'm dealing with
is all time series data.
And all the queries
are time base.
Will queries become more
expensive as the size of the
database increases?
Is it a good idea to shard
the database--
actually, this is
quite relevant--
shard the database into
monthly/biweekly tables to
optimize cost?
And the short answer is yes.
So yes, it is helpful to shard
the database, both for
performance as well
as for the cost.
So it really depends on what
types of queries that you're
going to run.
Are you running queries over
all of your data usually?
Or are you running queries
just over a specific
part of your data?
Most people with time-based
data, like I was saying
earlier, oftentimes, they're
just running queries over the
last week or the last month.
We even have people, some of
our developers, that are
sharding their data by hour,
because that's the type of
access that they often need,
is just looking at it on an
hourly by hourly basis.
And then you can even
do things--
I believe we have a way that you
can express that the table
should expire.
So as your data gets old and
know you don't actually need
to have data, maybe, from
five years ago, you can
automatically expire those
tables as it goes on.
So that's very helpful.
And sharding, because we are
embracing the concept of the
full table scan, you're
basically charged for the size
of all the columns that you're
querying times the number of
rows that are in your table.
And it's that complete table,
because we're doing a full
table scan each time.
So shard your data, definitely,
if you're often
doing queries that are over just
a segment or sub-part of
your overall data.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: These
are really good
questions, by the way.
RYAN BOYD: Yeah, absolutely.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: So it says
the next question is--
RYAN BOYD: That's the one
we just answered.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: We
answered that one.
According to the BigQuery web
site, we are charged on the
data processed in each column
selected in the query.
What exactly does data
process mean?
Is this the amount of data
being accessed to
return a data set?
Well, it's the amount of data
being accessed to return your
query result, so yes, that
is how we charge.
This is actually a very
economical way to charge
because, if you only select a
certain set of columns to
return your query result, you're
only charged for the
columns that the query touches,
not the rest of the
columns in your table.
So that makes the queries as
economical as possible.
RYAN BOYD: And actually, from
a performance perspective as
well, we store this data in
a column-based format.
So we're only actually reading
data off of disk that
represents the columns that
you're accessing.
So, basically, the way that
we're charging you directly,
maps onto our underlying cost
and, basically, the time that
it takes to read that
data off of disk.
So that's an important part of
BigQuery, because most of our
customers are actually not
needing to query across every
single one of the columns
in their tables.
So the row-based structure
doesn't work well for them,
but the column-based structure
of BigQuery does work well.
And in terms of what exactly
does data process mean, it's
really just the number of
bytes in the column, the
columns that you're accessing,
so the size of each of the
columns times the number of
rows that we talked about.
And I think one more question
here on quantile queries.
You've done a little bit
more of that, so why
don't you answer it.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Yeah, I'm
really interested in this one.
So quantile queries do not allow
any kind of grouping by
another column.
Do you have plans to allow
this in the future?
And this person is going to
group by medians and 99th
percentile the time.
This is a really interesting
question.
So currently, BigQuery's
Quantile function merely
buckets data into any number of
buckets that you want, but
doesn't allow for a further
group-by function.
We've been talking about this.
We don't have any news to
report, but we're looking into
ways to improve the Quantile
function to provide additional
functionality, like grouping the
buckets by a certain other
value in another column.
So that doesn't exist yet, but
we're looking into it.
And we're glad that you have
some use cases for it.
It's interesting to see that
people are looking to BigQuery
to do things like this.
Another thing you could do, by
the way, is you could take the
result set and feed that into
another program that does
additional statistical
analysis.
It's easy to get the results
back as a CSV form where you
can pipe that into something
like R, into a data frame with
R or some other statistical
packages.
So you can also do that.
RYAN BOYD: And oftentimes, for
those statistical type
queries, people will use the
Hash function in BigQuery to
select a random subset
of their data.
So they'll select 1/10 of the
data or 1/100 of their data.
And that allows you to do those
statistical analyses on
what was big data.
But you're selecting the
random subset to do the
analysis on.
And then you can verify your
results by then selecting a
different random subset,
et cetera.
So what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to quickly
refresh, because I'm not sure
if this is actually
refreshing on us.
So I'm going to quickly refresh
the screen here, and
we'll see if there's any other
questions that you guys have
put into the Moderator here.
And if there are any other
questions, we'll answer them.
If not-- it doesn't look like
there are any other questions.
So maybe we should thank
you all for joining
our show here today.
And I do want to say that
these types of questions
provide great value for us
to understand what you're
thinking about and
us to understand
your feature requests.
So although, for instance, we
don't support what was just
asked about the Quantile
functions that people are
looking for, just asking them
here today allows us to know
that you're looking for that
type of functionality and
allows us to prioritize
it better in our
upcoming road map.
So thank you.
My name is Ryan Boyd.
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: And I'm
Michael Manoochehri.
RYAN BOYD: And this
is the Ryan and
Michael show, or the--
MICHAEL MANOOCHEHRI: Michael
and Ryan show.
Live from London.
[LAUGHS]
RYAN BOYD: Take care.